and the video got out about me telling
coach prom I want to go back on the
field this week I need to play this week
we need to get everything we can so I
can get
do you think send me that
how did you know that
because what
[Music]
no you ain't ready and I care about your
boy and I care about this game you're
going to change the game of football one
day when you help them ready the future
is brighter than mine ever will be It
Ever Was relax and get healthy I love
you son that was the conversation
I care about y'all when I care about
this game but I want you to learn
throughout this game and through our
trials and tribulations Who You Are
yeah man I'm texting that bro it's just
hard to send my my teammates my brothers
go out there
work and then I know I'm just a missing
piece at the end of the day
just it's just hard I mean I love
playing with them guys and I mean we
we've been through it all we've been
through summer all the people hating on
us doubting us people want to hop on the
bandwagon after we win a couple games
then when we lose we get more hate
there's a lot of people always hating
and that is the part that give me the
most is I can't be out there in like go
ahead and dominate so we'll have no
excuses
so people won't have nothing to say I
mean I just like going out there and
playing at the end of the day helping my
team become the best team we we came
here to do we came here to be and that's
pretty much
like all I gotta say for that man I love
team to death man I know one of the top
one of the cabinets one of the top dogs
man
I know without me it's kind of hard for
them to Just Adjust in one week not even
a couple days so
that's all it is